since the all-star game he's averaged 23  points  eight rebounds and four assists and  tonight  harris has 19 11 and four double double  again  that'll be his 11th of the season  lee gets a three got it nice shot  outside  damien lee puts in a triple that's his  second  and he's got 16. for the 76ers  you see lee there knocking down that  triple  off of a great iso and steph enjoying  himself right now  watch out for the elbow might be feeling  a little better yes  settle down  and harris wasn't able to get around him  warriors  were all around ready to to help  and steph was pointing it out no you  can't do that you can't run over my guy  it wants to scott away also barking  there  by six the bench trying to resuscitate  them steph curry likes  the comeback by his warriors